[موسيقى]
في امل في امل يحكموه وتهكلي يشرب فش وسوى
هيك رجع لي بقول لي اعطوه براءه
انا مخي
انا من ساعه مدريد بالخبر وهذا سطح راسي
طاير
من لحظتها طار مش حاسه بالدنيا لو بايدي
لاطلع مكانه اصيح يا ورديه لما جبناه من
ابو كبير هذا وجهه كان كله كفوف انه يعني
انه كانوا مسكينه وضاربينه قبل ما يقتلوه
[موسيقى]
رنا الحلاق ام اياد الحلاق
ولدت الشهيد اياد الحلاق اياد اكد انسان
عادي عندنا في الدار كان مميزه بشكل رهيب
هو نوعه كان
مش ربنا بيقطعهم كامل هدول بياخد منهم اشي
بيعطيهم اشي طيف توحد كان عنده صار عمره
ايات حوالي
بدا يعني يتحسن كنت اخذه معي على المعمل
لسا معي
يروح نروح نركب نيجي
الولد بحاله درس مساعد طباخ يوم تم استشهد
كان رايح يستلم شغله في متى يوم ساب
الاقصى كان مسكر
وكانوا بدهم يفتحوه يعني حكوا يفتحوه يوم
الحد هلا لما اياد شافوه لحاله ما فيش
معيده يوم السبت استفردوا فيه لما جبناه
من ابو كبير هذا وجهه كان كله كفوف انه
يعني انه كانوا مسكينه وضاربينه قبل ما
يقتلوه شافها معلمته
فحاله خاصه حتى غير هيك اياد كانت يحط
بطاقه على صدره انه مدرسه
ومبين يعني في البطاقه المحطوط على على
صدره هلا تقول له المعلمه هذا معي هذا معي
هذا معي
ما ردش عليه طخه باجره
لما شاف معلمته وهو مدخوخه باجره راح يركض
عندها اثبت انه تحميه اللهم اجوا زاحوا
المعلمه حتى تقول المع زحوها بقوه واجا
الشرطي كمل عليه هو على الارض
كيف بدنا نرفع محكمه يقولوا انه ما فيش
محاكم نقدر نعمل محاكم المحامين يركضوا
لما قبلوا انه يقبلوها المحكمه ان حوالي
ثلاث سنين وشهرين كل حوالي شهر منروح
محكمه بكون محكمه محكمه يقولوا لنا اه راح
ياخذ عشر سنين من عشر سنين لا 12 سنه كل
المحكمه الاخرانيه كنا فيها امبارح
قعدنا لسه اول ما دخلت القاضيه وقفنا لسه
ما ولا كلمه حكاه
اعطته براءه يعني هيك قالت له انت بريء
وابصر ايش وانا وقفت لها يعني انت ايش
اللي بتعمليه كلمتين ثلاثه خفوها يا
القاضيه بطلت تبين جايبه عيلتها قال
يحموها خايفه منها
هيك برضو الدليل على انه جايين القرار
وقفت بعد ما اعطت القرار واحنا هشنا انا
والاب واخواته
[موسيقى]
اللي تبعونا وما رجعوا لناش اياهم اما في
كانوا عنا كاميرات واخذوهم من عندنا
صادروهم
[موسيقى]
بس انا بالنسبه الي
مش متعشمه العداله اذا كان غريب يا بني
لمين بدك تشكي اذا القاضيه غريمك اذا
القاضيه مستوطنه وكل الشهود معه مستوطنين
كل دار في القدس او الضفه فيها ماساه
كل دار فيها ماسه كل عيله فيها معاناه
سواء سجن سواء هدم سواء استشهاد وقتل
وابني راح قتل